in the midst of russia's War in Ukraine
and increased Western sanctions Russian
President vladimir Putin is in China for
Talks aimed at strengthening Trade
between The Two countries Putin Met With
Chinese President SH Jin Ping on the
sidelines of a Trade Forum She told
Putin that Trade between  China and
Russia has reached an historic High and
they've maintained Close and effective
strategic coordination adding that CH
and russ are Moving towards
Joint
billion
firstly, of course it is
harmful, it will create additional threats and
secondly, we
will of course be able to repel these attacks
there is a war  war and
of course I said that they do not pose a
threat, that goes without saying, of course, but they are
not able to change the situation on the
contact line, it is impossible for Ukraine in
this sense, there is nothing good either, it
just prolongs
the agony. So they started a long time ago; it was already
announced
and the
expected next counter-offensive is
now on  in the Kherson direction there is
no result yet, there are losses,
they are being drawn into this conflict, they are being
drawn into this, this is an obvious fact, and let
no one say that they have nothing to do with this,
we believe that they have,
plus, against the backdrop of the Middle East
conflict, all this is happening, this is
heating up the atmosphere. So they took and
dragged two  aviation groups in the
Mediterranean
Sea, I want
to say
that they will
inform the forces, the Russian military space
forces are starting on a permanent
basis. And
patrols in the neutral zone of the
airspace on the Black Sea
and our MiG-31 aircraft are armed with
dagger complexes